let's get back to the phones we now we
call them phones they're really the
internet tubes we're taking calls via
discord at davidpakman.com
discord let's go to jane from singapore
jane from singapore you're on the air
hi hi how are you i
am i'm very well thank you wow i'm
surprised you called on me
oh no jane from singapore is exactly
what we would gravitate towards
i i think that your show has been very
enlightening for me
thank you and i basically
signed up to be a member because i
watched your video with um
uh this this other guy um i can't
remember his name though
um and basically i thought he was so
he was a right-wing um believer i
believe and you were just so
polite and so conversational and so
accepting of listening to his views and
i just respected that so much
wow i can tell you who that was was it
uh was it maybe tim poole was he wearing
a hat during the interview
no it was it was a black guy who
who just said peterson jesse lee
peterson
yes that's right that's the one got it
so i mean i i think that you know
the way the u.s system has been running
it's
it's a great disappointment because we
all look to the us as
honestly a shining beacon of democracy
and i'm just wondering honestly you know
how
how the system would run with i mean
even republicans
showing a great drift um
you know on one hand you have a bunch of
guys who are
denying that the elections outcomes are
uh illegitimate and in the other hand
people are saying you know uphold
election results the republicans are
saying there's no fraud how does that
even work in a party
how do you go forward from here yeah i
mean listen it's it's really a question
for them to answer because
as someone who's on the left i see it
and i say this is corrosive and
destructive to democracy
this is going to um uh
lead to if this is believed by a
significant portion of the population
it's going to lead to all sorts of
follow-on problems
to me it seems untenable and
unsustainable now it's interesting that
you're saying from the perspective of
looking at what's going on from
singapore
it's not so much that you find it funny
you find it disturbing it sounds like
i do yeah i find it i find it how
how trump has weaponized the two words
fake news
i'm very disturbing people you know how
how do people raise
kids on such values i mean you know
there's always talk about the
recovery um healing the country
but do the people democrats and
republicans the people on you know on
the street
do they actually take the first steps
towards recovery towards conversation
towards dialogue
no of course in fact i i would expect
so if donald trump announces that his
2024 candidacy soon
i think that we will have four years of
of insanity once again
um and i think that either way the
presence of these propaganda media
outlets like newsmax and oan that are
going to
i mean they are go i can't even guess
what sorts of conspiracies they will
come up with about joe biden over the
next four years
it's going to be the opposite of healing
that we see here
can i ask a question just just get your
viewpoint yeah
um do you think that donald trump will
try to cut a deal with with
the doj perhaps to say
you know i will i will completely accept
the election results
if you guys just not charged me
or pursue any sort of criminal
investigations no chance because so so
because here's the thing here's the
thing if he does it now
it's his own doj so so what that that
doesn't make sense
and then that's not something that the
biden do i mean biden will be president
in a month you know so biden doesn't
need to cut any deals with anybody and i
i don't see i think the only way trump
can get himself out of trouble
preemptively
would be resign and mike pence pardons
him i don't think he will do it but
there are rumors he's thinking about it
i see i see because this is what we're
talking about in singapore we're sort of
betting that he would
he would step down in peace and say i
will give you country peace
only if you know right guys do not
prosecute me
yeah i don't think that will happen i
don't think that will happen no
all right anyway good luck and all the
best and i hope that there will be a
very smooth
and gorgeous inauguration ceremony for
biden
thank you jane from singapore very much
appreciate the call
uh great to hear from folks not just all
over the country but all over the world
let's go next to um let's go to
kyle from daytona beach florida
kyle from daytona beach florida you're
on the air
mr pacman can you hear me yes i can
excellent it's a pleasure to speak with
you the pleasure is all my content is
thank you thank you your content is very
intellectually stimulating
it's a nice reprieve from everything
that i have to hear every day living in
a red state
thank you now i i know that some people
are going to get mad at me because they
say i listen i haven't brought up
anybody's connection at all
but we are getting sort of like an
electricity type static
as well as a banging noise so i'm
wondering what you're doing
i'm sitting on my bed i can turn off the
fan and shut my bedroom's door
quickly you're not crinkling pieces of
paper over the phone by chance
wow oh my god we're gonna have to turn
that down that isn't
okay yeah we're gonna have to disconnect
that's just that was i don't even know
that that's legal in some states
um we're going to i really want to hear
from you but we're going to have to get
i can't subject the audience to that and
the audiologists in the audience are
filing lawsuits so
not going to be able to do that at this
point in time